problema número 163 una ensalada de
frutas está compuesta por manzanas
duraznos y uvas que están en una
proporción de 6 a 5 a 2 si se prepararán
39 kilos de esta mezcla cuántos
kilogramos más habrá de manzanas que de
uvas
los datos que nos dicen es que la
proporción de manzanas con respecto a
los duraznos y con respecto a las uvas
es de 6 a 5 a 2
nos preguntan la diferencia entre los
kilos de manzanas menos los kilos de
uvas
y no dicen que la suma de todo esto que
hace esta rica ensalada de frutas las
manzanas más los duraznos más las uvas
base de igual a 39 kilos y aquí la
manera más sencilla de trabajar las
proporciones es pensar en las manzanas
como 6 x un número mi cantidad de
manzanas va a ser igual a 6 x un número
que todavía no conozco que le llamo x
si esta es la cantidad de las manzanas
cuál va a ser la de los duraznos los
duraznos será igual a 5 por equis y por
lo tanto la cantidad de las uvas va a
ser igual a 2 por equis usemos esta
información que mantiene las
proporciones indicadas y vamos a
sustituirla en m + d + 1
así pues m es 6x más de 5x más o es 2x
todo esto es igual a 39
6 5 11 2 13 13 x es igual a 39
por lo tanto x es igual a 39 entre 13
39 13 es igual a 3 si yo multiplico 3
por 3 se eleva a 39 y ahora vamos a
sustituir el valor de x es 3x para
encontrar la cantidad de manzanas y de
uvas
la cantidad de manzanas es igual a 6 por
x x es 36 por 3 es igual a 18
la cantidad de duraznos es igual a 5 por
315 la cantidad de uvas es igual a 2 por
36 por lo tanto la pregunta de manzanas
menos uvas es igual a 18 menos 6 que es
igual a 12 kilogramos esta es la
diferencia
y esta es mi opción b
siguiente problema
número 164 louis tiene x dólares más que
juan y entre ambos tienen 10 dólares
cuál de los siguientes representa la
cantidad de dólares que tiene juan
tiene lo que tiene juan más equis
dólares
louis masjuán entre los dos tienen
nos preguntan cuánto es la cantidad que
tiene juan
sustituyamos la primera ecuación es la
segunda por lo que está l la sustituyó a
cam j más x + x
+ j
igual ayer nos quedan dos jota más x
igual a james
es 2 j estamos aquí si en ambos lados
nos queda menos x
finalmente jota al dividir todo entre 2
nos va a quedar menos x entre 2 y esta
es mi opción
siguiente problema
durante siete temporadas un equipo ganó
el 80 por ciento de esos primeros 100
partidos y el 50% de los restantes si el
equipo ganó el 70% del total de los
juegos de la temporada cuál fue el
número total de partidos que jugó en esa
temporada así que nos dicen que el 80%
de los primeros 100 partidos fueron
ganados y después ganaron el 50% de los
partidos restantes y ganaron el 70% del
total de los partidos de la temporada
si queremos calcular el porcentaje de
todos los partidos que ganaron vamos a
tener 80 que es el 80 por ciento de 180
más punto 5 por r que es el 50 por
ciento del resto entre el total de los
partidos qué es
+ r y esto es igual a punto 7
multiplicamos ambos lados por 100 más r
nos va a quedar 80
punto 5 r
igual a punto 7% igual a 70 más puntos 7
multiplique esto por esto restamos
puntos 5 er en ambos lados 80 es igual a
70.7 r - punto 5 erre va a ser igual a
más puntos 2
restamos 70 en ambos lados nos queda 10
igual apuntó 2 r dividimos todo en 3.2
nos quedan 10 entre punto 2 es igual a r
esto es lo mismo que tener 10 entre un
quinto punto 12 es igual a un quinto
qué es lo mismo que tener 50 y nos
preguntan el número total de partidos
jugados que es 100 más ere acabamos de
encontrar ere 100 más ere 100 más 50
pues va a ser igual a 150
qué es la opción d
el siguiente problema
número 166 de 30 candidatos para un
empleo 14 tienen cuatro o más años de
experiencia 18 tienen título y 3 tienen
menos de 4 años de experiencia y no
tienen título cuántos candidatos tienen
al menos 4 años de experiencia y título
anotemos los datos las personas con
experiencia mayor a 4 años son 14
las personas con título título título
son 18
las personas que tienen experiencia
menor a 4 años y no tienen título no
título
son 3
vamos a analizar esto nos dicen que el
total de los aplicantes o de los
candidatos todo este universo de los
candidatos son 30 personas de estas 30
personas una parte de ellas vamos a
dibujarlo así una parte de ellas va a
tener más de 4 años de experiencia
que son 14 que tienen la experiencia
experiencia mayor a 4 años y voy a tener
otro grupo y este grupo lo voy a dibujar
acá quizás no muy proporcionado
porque debería ser mayor éste que éste
pero bueno
vamos a poner que estas son 18 personas
que tienen título
y están las otras personas que tienen
experiencia menor a 4 años y no tienen
título es decir que están fuera de estos
círculos estarán por acá y son 3
personas sin experiencia y sin título
lo que nos preguntan está en esta
intersección esta parte de acá los que
tienen experiencia mayor de 4 años y
tienen título
bueno cuál es la suma de este conjunto
de aquí este circuito
este círculo
y este otro
que estoy remarcando y que me estoy
tardando en remarcar pero bueno ustedes
tengan paciencia
ok cuando se suma de estos dos pues va a
ser el total menos las tres personas que
no están en estos círculos que serán 27
son 27 personas que tienen una
experiencia mayor a 4 años o un título y
cómo voy a relacionar esto con el 14 y
el 18
qué pasa si sumamos el 14 y el 18 bueno
a sumar los 14 vamos a sumar las
personas en la intersección una vez y al
sumar los 18 de este lado vamos a sumar
otra vez las personas que están en esta
intersección para obtener los de ambos
círculos vamos a sumar 14 más 18 pero
resta haremos lo de la intersección este
27 va a ser igual a 18
- lo de la intersección esta
intersección los voy a llamar b
ve hagamos la operación
27 es igual a 18 14 es igual a 32 32
nos ven esta vez me es igual
a 32 27
que es igual a 5 y esta es mi opción
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo